[Musique]
c'est super d'être de retour c'est tellement bon d'être
là
même avec des masques je viens d'en trouver un qui
allait avec mon cosplay qu'il porte comme celui-ci
est le vrai métal
[Musique]
c'est le cosplay ça me manque de cosplayer
s'habiller avec mes amis venir ici
en tant que groupe surtout manquer les panneaux
et voir tous mes artistes préférés tous
mes mangaka préférés et aimer jouer à
des jeux vidéo et rencontrer beaucoup de
personnes uniques intéressantes qui partagent le
même intérêt que vous parce qu'il est vraiment
difficile de trouver des gens en dehors de la bande dessinée
qui partagent les mêmes intérêts que vous
[Musique]
et je ne peux pas porter ça au supermarché
d'habitude donc c'est très agréable d'être avec des
gens qui connaissent la mode ou qui s'y
intéressent aussi et je peux sortir et aimer
parader c'est très amusant
[Musique]
toi